[Music]
in pointed fingers news poof point
improve point Cheska come out soon
submitted by a big black box a Girl
Scout leader was fired after her viral
cookie theft story crumbled oh she lied
she hated it all and she was like huh
you're not gonna believe what happened
she Cookie Monster just came and all
this [ __ ] that's what happened to me
when I was a kid when you have to sell
chocolates I kept on eating them
you're a Girl Scout I was Girl Scout but
then you know like in school you have to
sell candy bars all the fundraisers I
always ate my own I got mine too you
know about the Girl Scout that's trying
to be a boy scout
yeah that's cool oh because she wants to
be an eagle or whatever right but they
don't get boys hella horny and they
don't learn the same [ __ ] oh really no
I'd rather be in the Boy Scouts
what's that one actual like life skills
yeah it's Dobis foil they're gonna make
stew that's dope
I want to learn how to make stew you
don't know how to make steel Boy Scouts
when you go camping bicha tent though
you should have the same criteria for
both the old school though that's why
it's not the same company it's not yeah
so the Girl Scout is started by this
kind of aristocrat lady and then during
that time it would be bad for the family
if she would work but then it was like
she had that title in that pedigree but
then um basically what happened was she
needed to make money because they were
actually broke because of some [ __ ] that
went down but then also it would bring
shame to her ancestors if she worked a
job so she created the Girl Scouts and
then that became her business so it was
just totally different it was like to
[ __ ] build women up to do [ __ ] Boy
Scouts war ready around yeah yeah yeah
yeah girls got some more like like girly
stuff sewing and [ __ ] like that all my
badges were like [ __ ] sewing and
cooking because that's what a lot of
girls skills were back in a day right
like [ __ ] baking and at home and [ __ ]
I mean none of that [ __ ] dude I watched
naked and afraid' rub all that [ __ ] man
I shake magnesium for no [ __ ] reason
your well can't be I'll bring matches
dude I just get that [ __ ] bling [ __ ]
does they have those in keychains - yeah
but those are wack dude I got I got
don't best one those at 120 bucks it's
pretty tight yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ] spot
oh yeah we weren't counting together yup
so when we go camping our cars like 10-4
um could you just cigarette lighter -
yeah but we did it look we did it and we
bought Tupperware and all this [ __ ] yeah
we had steaks and stuff is different we
had bomb-ass food that time it was
pretty [ __ ] good all right so this
story here happened in New Jersey
joycie troop leader named Jessica she's
38 years old she has two daughters in
this troop one aged five the other one
age 11 so it was reported that a
cold-hearted crook snatched more than
1100 dollars from these girls when they
were she stole baby kids bunnies so hold
on so they set up their cookie table on
the upper level of a mall on Mira
chick-fil-a and so they were hoping to
raise enough money to go on a trip to
Savannah where the founder of Girl
Scouts once lived so anyway so Jessica
said that there was a thief that
approached them with an older woman who
was using a red Walker and seemed to be
handicapped himself and he and so they
asked to buy a box or like two boxes and
so she was helping her daughter take
care of the transaction so then she says
that she set the cash envelope
containing 500 dollars and some checks
on the table and when she was helping
her daughter that she was behind as he
was and then he reached over grab the
envelope and slipped it in his jacket
and that immediately the guy was telling
the woman like okay let's go let's go
let's go and then that big just quickly
that um so then she was on her way out
she was like wait what happened in that
envelope like did I drop it like where
did it go and she was like well first I
didn't respect that man because he
appeared to have special needs take a
steel tube she said that he was rocking
back and forth and slurring but then she
said that policeman said that that was
probably an Act passed true yeah just so
so people wouldn't like stare at him
it's like the prestige oh yeah the
prestige pretty smart you don't want
people don't want to get caught staring
they just don't look I'm like if you
look strange in the neighborhood who you
gonna call me cuz I have no shame I'll
just [ __ ] watch you like a hawk so
then they're saying like this and the
initial report of this whole thing
they're saying that you could clearly
see in the camera footage this man's
behavior and it looked like he had his
eyes on the envelope the entire time and
he was pretending to have special needs
and people would assert so like he had
special needs like in what way cuz the
grandma was blind right she did show up
with the woman with the red walk okay
but I don't know she was okay with the
walker that I thought walking stick so I
imagine like a you know like a special
guy in a trench coat I stick with the
red thing yeah and then his his grandma
was like my glasses you know what I mean
like with the paint that's what I
thought
a tenday they [ __ ] teamwork this [ __ ]
this is the first time he's actually
used those glasses for a actual purpose
that makes sense so I'm proud and I knew
it would come in handy see that's why I
don't [ __ ] throw away things dude
does it spark joy hell yeah I thought
okay dude all of this [ __ ] I got that
answer wrong in my driving test like can
anyone carry a white cane and I put yes
because in my mind I thought like a pimp
cane in a white I like calling your
driving test it makes sense to me like
okay yeah that's fine what matters
sometimes those tests though I feel like
they want people that are a little bit
stupid yeah because the questions that
you asked I'm just like yeah anyone can
technically carry it why would you think
that people wouldn't say it like are you
supposed to cross the white line did you
write no snort it snort it oh I imagined
like a pimp what matches came with this
outfit and a white I can see him wearing
a white furry outfit and a white pimp
cane it made sense to me
so I'm running over one people find this
story here so one of the little girls
she was the one that said about the
security footage thing right then this
story went viral and the whole community
came together and we gotta [ __ ] find
these guys it's just like no no it's
cool it's cool I learned my lesson like
people from the mall too like they came
together and they offered to pay about
3,500 fund that trip to go to Savannah
Georgia log the [ __ ] people are
awesome yeah and then and now the most
recent thing here is that the police are
saying that Jessica actually stole the
money
[ __ ] Jessica the mob which is this is
Jessica Jessica Jessica
that's not Jessica and then this is this
photo was one of the girls Oh
from the money missing that's uh this is
like the whole troupe they're all sad
yeah they're all like really sad because
they really want to go on that trip this
week I can get did the mom swipe that
money in the middle of all of this and
she put she blamed it on the on this
special guy yeah pretty much exactly
that that she was the one that that
stole it that is some low a [ __ ]
according to the security footage the
cops say that there was never anyone
else near the mall that wasn't disabled
and then that the the money stayed
secured in a cash box the entire time so
they were locating the accused men and
woman but then eliminated I'm a suspect
and then the cops are saying that she
changed her story saying that the cash
wasn't from the cookie sell after all
but rather previously submitted by the
Girl Scouts to pay for scouting event
such as roller skating and a daddy
daycare dance that she was planning to
deposit in the bank so she was like whoa
it wasn't or the cops are saying yeah
she said that it wasn't the actual
cookie money so some other what money
right and then on a check it was written
cookie specifically for Hannah you
[ __ ] [ __ ] so I so for sure what
happened was that when they were selling
cookies she did really didn't think that
they were gonna get up to $1,000 and
then she saw that money she goes holy
[ __ ] people actually buy these [ __ ]
cookie
you know how much math I could smoke
with that that's what she was thinking
they don't know like when a little
[ __ ] girl comes up and says excuse me
sir would you like to try this me me
take it goddamn it you [ __ ] too
little [ __ ] exactly can you imagine
layer [ __ ] come up and then she has a
box of cookies she's not the size for
cookie box yeah I'm on do you want me to
buy that she don't say not dragging it
yeah and she start crying if I take the
box no you keep the [ __ ] box - then
[ __ ] lay looks like the [ __ ] Monsters
Inc girl dude she dies boom yeah do it
if they get that elephant ellaby - I'm
gonna [ __ ] myself thank you what is it
Oh wreck-it Ralph oh yeah so then the
cops in Villa like we finished it saying
that once they presented this to her
that she agreed with the findings saying
that maybe she accidentally threw it in
the trash when the scouts are clean Oh
excuses excuses the Girl Scouts of
central and southern New Jersey said
that they removed Jessica from her
volunteer position as troop leader and
they were like we're really surprised
and we're very sad in at the turn of
events but then Jessica Jessica comes
back and says no the cops made that up I
never changed my story they just said
that it would not look good on the town
if we arrest a special-needs guy why
would I need a steal money why would I
just need to steal a thousand dollars my
husband makes $200,000 a year
rich people steal I've got $50,000 with
the cookie sitting in my house right now
I've got thousands of thousands of
dollars of cookie deposits that come in
every Thursday like I would never need
to steal this it's just the cops changed
a story because they didn't want the
town to look bad
why would a town look bad I wouldn't I
would have been like you [ __ ] town
and then she also added that the the
money that was offered to the girls got
like the troop that the troop themselves
never saw a single penny from all that
donated money and that the local chapter
was taking care of the pledges wait the
GoFundMe money they never saw it
I wish that's what she claimed what is
happening that sounds like beaver E to
me I don't know what's going on but I
don't trust nobody those little girls
are in on it too [ __ ] those little girl
dude stupid chair all suspects yeah who
know it's probably you know when you
have such a good products though like I
saw most sad symbol is hiding that let's
see his dick once in the whole show and
I'm very upset I know me too
whose dick is little more on out Khal
Drogo oh oh
didn't get the serious dick once you
wanted to huh yes you know trying to
spank bank it it's like we saw titties
is so funny you saw some dicks
you see Andre joystick I want to see
he's clearly then you're gonna see more
doors dick it's huge
oh I didn't remember either until ice we
saw it again I was like I'll [ __ ] [ __ ]
doors dick oh yeah that was big dick
yeah no no it's a big dick oh the holder
has a big day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]